snico once an amazing philosophical
YouTuber now to an outraged red pill
streamer that just likes to scream into
the camera wake up
wake up over the last six months since
starting YouTube my network has expanded
rapidly I've met tons of different crazy
people you heard of the based mother one
of them being snico in this video I'm
going to show you snico's true colors
and what he's really like behind the
scenes I'm also going to give my
thoughts on some of snico's more
controversial takes and the current beef
going on with moist critical so the
first time I ever actually spoke to
snico was on that live stream back in
August I did with my mother your mom
belongs to the streets oh yeah she's
like hell yeah I belong to the streets
I'm from Brooklyn
about a month into my content creation
Journey so I remember being pretty
nervous going into it you know going
from sitting behind a camera where
you're watching a video with your mom
next to you to then having a talk in
front of 10 000 people live that's a big
jump and I definitely remember [__]
my pants a little bit but you know
sneako was nice on it and my mom was
super relaxed she made sure to hold it
down uh from there me and sneako didn't
speak too much
um you know just swiping up on each
other's Instagram stories texting a
little bit about [__] but nothing
too crazy to be honest
um a couple months go by of just texting
once in a while and I finally met him
for the first time I believe it was
mid-January and me and my mom went to
his place in Miami to meet him for a
live stream surprisingly you know you
think that going to meet snico in person
and and be doing content live I'd be
even more nervous but I was surprisingly
really relaxed I'm not sure how many of
you guys are into online business but a
lot of the time that you talk with
people strictly online and then meet
them in person for the first time it's
pretty awkward but I remember meeting
snico he came to the apartment door let
us in and I didn't feel awkward or
nervous at all honestly I felt 10 times
more comfortable than I did sitting at
my own desk talking to him through a
Discord call which is pretty interesting
but yeah it's funny a lot of the times
it is awkward but I don't know we had a
good energy and I wasn't really nervous
at all the live stream ended up going
really well I'll leave the link in the
description too for those of you guys
that want to go check it out Sunny has
no ribs since I was staying in Miami
sneak was actually very hospitable he
came picked us up at the or picked me up
at the hotel and then we went and got
some steak and stuff I gotta say meeting
him um and being able to actually just
talk one-on-one off of camera was
actually really really cool you know you
get everything you see on camera
um it's only a watered-down version of
what guys like us really talk about I'm
sure you know that even when you're you
know you're talking in school or in
front of other people it's not the same
as when you're talking with just your
boys alone so getting to hear a lot of
like other celebrities stories and some
of the stuff that he's talked about on
stream but the unfiltered version it was
actually like a really cool experience
and he was nothing but nice to be honest
you know he paid for the food which is
always a good gesture you know something
I notice when you're going out with
people is if they're stingy about paying
for something like dinner or they don't
even offer it's always a red flag you
know if people are going to be little
[__] about small amounts of money
then going into business with them for
large amounts is never really a good
idea so first experience meeting snico
live stream getting food smoking cigars
on his balcony super dope dope ass
experience gotta say I said Asians can't
drive from here we stayed in touch a
little bit more texting
um talking whatever reacting to each
other's content all that all that
[__] uh YouTuber and Rumblers do
then the next time I went down to Miami
we met up again food cigars doing some
work same kind of stuff but this time it
was during the day so it's actually a
totally different experience being with
him basically every single place that I
went to with him he got recognized which
I'm not used to I've gotten recognized a
few times but nothing too crazy and I
gotta say it was non-stop positive
interactions everywhere we went and zico
was nothing but nice and down to earth
Earth to all the people that came up to
us I remember we were sitting at a lunch
place in Brickell and some guy came over
and he was showing him like his tattoo
work and sneaker was like genuinely
interested he was telling him like shoot
me a DM that's really cool stuff yeah
let's stay in touch and you know I could
definitely say a lot of these other
celebrities and people they would just
get kind of annoyed with you and they
would they would just brush you off but
seeing the genuine impact that sneako
has had on these people or at least how
they they make it seem to him he's
nothing but nice to them even at the gym
people multiple people were coming up to
him in between sets and he was just
shooting [__] being a cool guy I gotta
say it's honestly so cringy seeing all
the hate that he gets online because I
know for a fact that if any of these
people saw snico in person they'd go up
tell them how much of a big fan and
inspirational he is and then asked to
take a picture you might deny it now but
I can guarantee if you met a famous
person you could get some attention from
you wouldn't be going up to them talking
about their sex life from four years ago
you would go up and be nice to them like
most normal humans are that's definitely
something that's changed over the last
10 years since phones have become such a
normal part of people's lives where
people will literally talk [__] to
someone online and never say it to their
face which is so fascinating they take
this International too far bro
it's gonna get back though honestly I
think stiko's a pretty relatable guy and
I think that's a big reason of why he's
so famous you know from the
inappropriate jokes to his thoughts to
his learning process it's something that
we see in ourselves and we can almost
like grow with him as we watch and learn
and take in new information one thing
that I see sneako get bash for Non-Stop
is the cuckold situation where he had
like a threesome or some [__] a few
years ago so I have a few points about
this one being you know snico has been
making content since he was like 13 or
14 years old I believe that's over 10
years of basically documenting your
entire life on the internet now I want
you to imagine if since you were 14
years old every good and bad thing that
you've done is documented on the
internet if you if you share this
publicly I mean that is [__] insane
you know I I've done some really stupid
stuff in my past where I could get
roasted non-stop for it but I just
wasn't sharing it on social media I'm
sure I'll share it one day some of the
Dumber stuff that I did but I mean you
do gotta keep keep that in mind like bro
has literally shared everything he's
done for the past 10 years and honestly
even talking about an experience like
what he went through in that cuckold
situation we're on the same bed I was
with his girl he was with my girl are
you on the bed yeah yeah what's wrong
with you so what did I couldn't like it
was I was literally having PTSD watching
that I was like having war flash it
takes balls to share that because a lot
of us have done embarrassing stuff so to
go on a podcast publicly and tell that
story which you know is embarrassing I
mean it's honestly like it's it's I can
respect it you know I'm not gonna sit
here and [__] on him too much especially
since it was a while ago he said he
tried the experience and he didn't like
it so I don't know people constantly
bringing up that same point I I don't
really get it you know also a lot of you
guys are hypocrites you know you're
jerking off to porn and buying only fans
I mean jerking off to porn you're
literally addicted to another guy
getting vagine and you're telling me
that's not gay I don't know what do I
know what do I know I'm just saying I
think that people roast him way too much
for that but I get it he's a big
influencer Twitter Geeks what are you
gonna do that's what comes with the fame
going off of that about documenting your
whole life and the internet I recently
just saw a story where an NHL player got
canceled for a racist joke he made in
eighth grade and people supported him
being canceled I don't know if everyone
on the internet just thinks they're
[__] saint but I can guarantee you
can dig into anybody's past and find
something to cancel them with anybody I
mean it's a running joke in guys that if
the PlayStation party got leaked we
would all be screwed so then everyone's
gonna go and get on their high horse and
cancel someone for a joke in eighth
grade like I don't know the only reason
I mention this is because snico talks
about embarrassing experiences from his
past and then people still want to roast
and cancel him for it which it's just
beyond me I mean we all know people grow
like if your thoughts aren't changing
every six months to a year there's
something wrong with you like every six
months I look back at myself from six
months before and I think that that
version of my self was [__] six
billion views in like two months that's
cool with the strategy um so yeah how
many months like three months like I
literally do this every six months and
that's because I'm constantly striving
for personal growth so if you're not
even getting to that point where your
mind is changing you're doing something
wrong I can guarantee even in six months
now I'm gonna look back at this video
I'm gonna be like damn you're way
skinnier damn you're [__] you don't
sound as articulate as you sound now
damn you don't make points as well you
know it's good to have to have growth so
if you're just gonna bash someone for
something they said years ago I don't
know just doesn't seem like the best use
of anybody's time it doesn't make sense
to me I'm not going to do that to
someone else but hey what are you what
are you gonna do my point being if you
wouldn't be cool with someone digging up
your entire past then don't get on your
high horse and roast people on the
internet for their past the next time I
hung out with Nico we actually got a gym
session in together now the past couple
months before going to the gym with Nico
this time I was being real Puss about it
you know I was doing some push-ups once
in a while in the house but you know I
really was out of my groove I wasn't
going to the gym consistently at all and
I was probably the most out of shape
that I've been in a good amount of time
so going to the gym with Nico he's been
going for you know I think six months
very consistently now and we didn't even
do anything too crazy you know we were
doing like bench press and then we did a
couple leg workouts and in the middle of
the leg workouts I ran to the bathroom
and puked because I was just trying to
keep up with him and I was so out of
shape and then I Remember by the end
when we were hitting the bag I could I
could barely do it anymore and I was
toast and I I remember feeling so
embarrassed in the moment you know going
with other guys like we all have that
fire inside of us where we want to
compete and be stronger than the dude
next to us and to feel so weak and by
the end not even be able to hit the bag
it it actually flipped the switch in my
head and I never wanted I I I just
didn't ever want to feel like that again
and since that exact day actually I
haven't missed another gym session and
I've been seeing pretty nice progress
since then so shout outs Nico you know
you actually helped get me back into the
gym and you know put a lighter under my
ass and Spark it for me to go to the gym
consistently again since then I actually
haven't seen snico he's been on a world
tour going to Dubai you just filmed the
movie now he's in like Thailand or some
[__] I don't know what bro's up to so
while sneako is on this world tour I
think he's in like [__] Thailand
right now he's going through some beef
with moist critical and everybody wants
everybody's thoughts on this situation
so I guess I have to give mine too and
to be honest my thoughts aren't too
crazy I think the whole situation is
just pretty childish you know internet
beef in my opinion is all just pretty
dumb because at the end of the day if
you just talk in person or at least face
to face there's levels of tension that
get released compared to just constantly
going back and forth making videos or
just quote retweeting each other but you
know I do understand both people's sides
you know sneako um he gets a lot of hate
so I could see why he's defensive and he
comes back at people hard he's been
hitting the gym so he wants to take that
[__] physically and box the dude plus a
lot of the hate snico gets is is pretty
dumb to be honest I mean a lot of these
hit pieces like I said they're just
going into old stuff he said bringing up
the cuckold situation you know digging
through hours and hours and hours of
footage to find small Clips where you
can place them together to make them
look bad so it's I don't know you know
all of us keep growing as people like I
said so if you're gonna take something
from seven months ago where snico's
saying he doesn't want to fight a guy
compared to now where his mind has
changed like I don't know I I just I
think that people grow and if you're
just gonna keep going to six month ago
clips and then to now it just doesn't
make sense because this is a currently a
different version of snico than six
months ago and then from moist critical
side I don't know I'm pretty sure well
snico added him to like that collage the
soya boy collage would piss them off and
then he gets into a rage like I don't
know bro it's all [__] dumb like you
really like does my opinion really
matter that much on this situation like
no like bro at the end of the day this
[__] doesn't matter you know all that
really matters is your success I mean
like it sounds dumb but like does this
does this help your life at all you know
like following along with like the
sneako moist critical beef no bro it
doesn't mean [__] it doesn't mean [__]
sneaker promotes a message he wants
people to go to the gym and better
themselves and find truth and I don't
know what moist critical promotes
probably some soy boy [__] I don't care
but it's like following along with this
beef bro like this is just this is
another layer to The Matrix in my
opinion where like girls watch the
Kardashians and then guys obsess over
this drama it's all dumb hope you
enjoyed my take on that I know that
wasn't too philosophical but I'm just
being straight up I don't give a [__]
you know I'm learning to fight I'm
hitting the gym I'm launching businesses
I'm learning to use guns like I'm trying
to build myself as a man even these guys
we look up to like Andrew Tate you think
that he's gonna go and start following
along with this donut with this dumbass
beef like no he wouldn't even if he's
out of prison of course so I don't know
what are you gonna do to add on to that
rant I just want you guys to remember
that everything in life is an energy
exchange so if you find yourself typing
and commenting negative [__] in Twitter
comments I want you guys to go into the
bathroom and stare at your soul through
the mirror to figure out what the [__]
you're doing with your life quite
literally you're putting negative energy
out into the universe and we all know
that that [__] comes back around once I
realize this even if I don't like a
video or Tick Tock or tweet a tweet or
something I'm not just gonna go and
comment some negative stuff to [__] on
them because I know that that energy
comes back around the words you speak
out there literally dictate your reality
so just keep that in mind when you're
throwing [__] up online plus a lot of
you guys are in your pre-success stage
as I like to call it so if you know
you're going to be successful one day
would you tweet this knowing that people
are going to be looking back into your
past
would you do this thing would you send
that dick pic would you send that horny
text no no successful you wouldn't do
that and you're in your pre-success
stage keep that in mind I'm glad that's
something that I always kept in mind
because it's pretty hard to find you
know dirt on me from from before I
actually had any clout because I always
knew I was going to make it one day so
I'm keeping that in mind you don't do as
much dumb [__] you don't put out as much
negative energy and another thing to
remember of course too is a lot of these
people that are tweeting in the replies
and stuff these are your competition in
life I see people replying to every
single one of my tweets and like 10
other guys the second they come out to
get ahead of the masses really isn't
that hard with Tick Tock and the mass
media machines controlling people's
brains right now simply working towards
a free mind and having some discipline
sets you apart from quite literally 99
of people and I'm not exaggerating that
even a lot of the most successful people
that I see at the top they're still
addicted to jewels they still scroll on
social media a lot of the time they just
allocate some of their time focused onto
making money some of their time you know
I'll see people I have a cousin this guy
works at a hospital one of the funniest
people that I know he works 40 hours a
week at a hospital and I try to tell him
if you take one week off and you
dedicate that 40 hours to just learning
about money and some ways to make cash
online you wouldn't need to work this
job anymore you would you wouldn't need
to work a job for fifty thousand dollars
a year if you took that 140 hour work
week and dedicated it to reading maybe
reading different books watching
different videos getting that course
starting a business and trying it that's
obviously the best way to learn because
then you fail and learn from your
mistakes no no I see a lot of these
people doing the same things you know
you guys waste so much of your time and
I do it too you know I'm not perfect I
waste time and I at least try it I at
least acknowledge it and I am aware that
I'm wasting time a lot of these people
aren't even aware that they're wasting
time and this is my point after your
competition these people live life on
monkey mode they go to work they come
home they smoke they drink on weekends
they eat when they're hungry they eat
what they want they don't consciously
think is this the best move that I can
be making right now sorry for my little
Tate rant but it's truth and hopefully
you know I I think some of you guys do
need to hear that because it is really
intimidating getting into the online
money space you know because a lot of
these entrepreneurs that you talk about
are constantly taking cold showers
waking up at six working 18-hour days
but bro at the end of the day if you're
just allocating like a few hours a day a
few hours a day to how to make money or
even trying something you're far ahead
of everybody else so far ahead overall I
believe snico is a net positive for men
any content that activates your brain
makes you think hit the gym start a
business is undoubtedly a good thing in
my opinion he's not promoting beating
women being a [__] he seeks truth
gives everyone a platform and reinforces
a lot of the good things that men need
to hear that none of these other
creators are talking about plus like I
said I believe a lot of us see ourselves
in sneako which makes him very relatable
which is always a good thing to see in
your career as they're seeking for
self-improvement so I don't know you
know I don't know [__] at the end of the
day you know I'm just another person
that shits every day too and has you
know my own thoughts and whatnot but
yeah you know I gotta say sitting in
front of Cameron talking alone is
definitely weird not doing reaction
videos with my mommy next to me it's
definitely interesting but yeah W snico
another thing too people are gonna call
me a dick rider for supporting sneako
when did when did this become such a
thing that you're a dick rider if you
support somebody or you defend them on a
tweet that's that's mind-boggling to me
like Defending Your Friends now or even
like just acquaintances whatever you
call it I consider myself friends with
Nico people [__] got mad that I
called myself friends with them [__]
idiots Twitter they [__] tweets
sometimes get in your head
but don't be afraid to defend people
that you like and stand up for what you
believe in you're not dick riding it's
awesome BS that's someone with no
brothers would say that you're dick
riding you think Justin Waller and Luke
Barnett and all those guys are dick
riding for supporting Tate no they're
friends they're brothers and that's what
you need to find but we all need some
brothers in a time like this all right
done with this speech make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram follow
sneak on Rumble shout out sneako and
like I said I left the link in the
description to that live stream I had
from earlier shout out creativity kit
and see you guys later
[Music]
on